Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it's time for the
Monday morning podcast from Monday,
February 29th,
2016 happy leap year. Oh,
happy leap year and a happy birthday
to the poor said conch who only have a
birthday once every four years, you know?
Good Lord.
Can you imagine going on that first day
with that broad bitch and about that?
I always feel left out.
It was like everybody else had
a birthday every single year.
It was like I would zero than
I was four then I was eight.
Okay.
You know she'd be in
good shape though. Huh?
He been fucking 75% less birth. Birthday,
birthday cake every year, right?
No. Wait. How does that math work out?
If in four years you had
four slices of cake, right?
But you were born in the leap
year. You only had one. Yeah.
That percentage doesn't work
because you know you have one.
Somebody else says two, they got
100% more than you got. Right.
They got all provided the there
equals slices. Now Jesus Bill,
you're going to do, you
going to break out fractions.
I think I'm gonna steal a little
birthday cake. Fractions. All right,
so they're getting fucking
300% more kick than you are,
man. I be, you know something. I've been,
anybody who's born on February 29th is
either a miserable cunt or just one of
the coolest laid back people like,
you know, oh my God, another birthday.
Aren't the years flying by?
No. No, they're not. Actually,
to be honest with you,
that's kind of weird.
So like when the fuck
are you actually like,
like say when you're 29
you know that doesn't work.
Do you 28 it's gotta be forced,
right? Wait, you're zero.
Jesus Christ. It should
be fucking annoying. Zero.
If you had a baby born on
the 29th right year, if
you're zero the first year. All right.
One, two, three no, four be back
again for right. I don't fucking know.
All I know is it's somebody's birthday
today and it hasn't been their birthday
since 2012 so happy fucking
birthday. What does that work out?
16 1514 1312 would be five years.
I can't fucking do it. I don't know
when it was. So once every three years
[inaudible]
oh, Jesus.
Anything that happens every four years
usually sucks to people's birthdays on
leap year of World Cup soccer,
the Olympics. You know,
I actually like Olympic hockey,
but then I hate all those fucking
do shit who never watch hockey.
And they'd be like, see if it was like
this, I would watch it all the time.
What? Only two weeks long with no
fighting. You fucking do shit. Beat it.
Nobody cares whether you
watch it or not. We stayed on.
At least I don't. So, um, anyways, I
apologize for the, uh, you know what?
I don't apologize. Oh,
I okay. I will, I will,
I'll apologize for the
podcast being this late.
I was going to do it on Sunday
when I was up in Foxwoods. Joe,
this go to the fucking casino. Wild
in the middle of words, you know.
Um, I was going to
record on Sunday, but uh,
[inaudible] got some tickets to see
the Yukon, uh, Houston cougars game up,
uh, you know, big fucking program by
the way, man. How about the fight?
You know, very quietly. I probably
shouldn't say very quietly.
I just don't pay attention to the
sports ladies hopes. You know,
I knew that fucking, uh,
Tennessee with pat summit, right.
Was fucking crushing it.
And I know Yukon was,
I thought they were doing all right,
but I thought it was mainly fucking
pat summit. And then I went to the
Goddamn Yukon game. I got a picture
of it here on my phone. You know,
somebody sent me a picture
of a friend of, uh,
a hairless pit bull that had freckles.
So most adorable thing you
ever seen in your life,
but the person said it look like me.
Okay.
Ah, I like a good tweet.
You know, I don't get,
I didn't give a shit if you break my
balls, if it makes me laugh. All right,
so the fucking lady,
the lady huskies. Well,
let's do it in order here.
Let's do the guys first.
Considering they have way less. You know,
you always want to build towards your
closing bit. All right, the guys,
the fellows have won four
national championships since 1999.
All right.
The Yukon men's huskies have one 1999
2004 2011 2014 that's very fucking
respectable. Is anybody want
more than that? I don't know.
I'm not going to look it up. Kentucky
or Duke, I would guess. Maybe not Duke.
Right. Do Go. All right. Um,
but the ladies,
they want at 95 they want it in 2000
2002 2003 2004 2009 then the fucking God
damn poor excuse for speakers.
Hang it from that fucking
building that they have with it.
Do the ceilings peeling is in the way.
The next two banners, they want it.
2014 2015 now I've got
to fucking look it up.
Well, as far as what I can see here on
the phone, that's one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight and there's
two other banners behind that.
That's gotta be a championship one. Yeah.
National Champions. What an asshole.
What a fucked and I walked down and take
it correctly or maybe look it up before
I did this. All right, hang on a
second. Hang on. Hang on. Hang on.
Oh, Jesus. No, I'm typing on my phone.
This is gonna take for fucking ever.
I looked at the up the most
random women's huskies.
Why would I write that? That's
not going to get me there.
Okay.
Yukon.
Huskies
championships. All right. Give me
the ladies. Give it the ladies,
but to come up for us. Uh,
the men's do you sexist
motherfuckers national championships?
Do you fucking hang on ladies,
ladies?
[inaudible]
there we go. Connecticut
women's basketball. I apologize.
I even know if I had an,
if had any fucking decency,
I would edit most of this out,
but I'm not gonna all right.
National Tournament champion
[inaudible] Conference Championships.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Nobody cares about any of this elite
age final four tournament champions.
95 2000 2002 2003 2004 2009
2010 2013 2014 2015 one,
two, three, four, five.
They wanted five out of the last six
fucking years and since the year 2000 Kona
bit, they've wanted one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine fucking times total domination.
Fuck a dog snoring. You
know my dog's getting fat.
I don't know what's going on
with that. He's changed his food.
We started getting her an extra can
cause she's always fucking coming over,
licking the bowl there. You know,
we felt bad for her and then I should say
she looks like a fucking state worker.
Right? Tennessee lady falls.
Alright, here we go. Come on
Wikipedia. Where the fuck are you
lady ball? Wait, what do you say? What
do you think? Because we think guys more.
Huh? I get it. Go was Connecticut
at that point of dull?
This might be the most boring
podcast ever. Well what do you do?
You get what you pay
for. All right, fuck it.
I'm not looking it up at the moment. My
eyes are seeing, I'm seeing double here.
I'm very impressed. But both of them,
man, they're, they're quietly crushing.
It's a nice small campus. They play
in this little ass building with,
with Shit Pale in from the ceiling.
The student section was hilarious.
You know when they
introduce the other team,
they sit there reading the newspaper.
I thought that was funny. Now,
I'm sure somebody going to say, well,
L K oil cord fucking university used
to do that. I don't give a shit.
So first time I saw it, it
was funny to me. Um, dude,
there was a guy sitting behind like
classic New England Sports Fan.
I never heard a guy like anytime the
ball didn't go in for the Huskies, he,
he had an a reason every fucking time
down the court and this is what killed me.
So I'm like, all right, this
guy's a total hoop head. Right?
And I turned around and Yaz on
a red sox hat and tee shirt toe.
He's basically a sports maniac, right?
The guy missed a shot. He'd be like, Eh,
didn't follow through. Next time they
come down the court, the DBA guy, the guy,
he should've been rotating around.
It's the second day I the double JB
should have been rotating around.
Next time down the court,
somebody slips. What?
Is there something wrong with the
floor? And I just kept nudging versa.
He would, he would go on like, like
the, like the fucking lady huskies here.
He would go on like four or five,
four or five hour runs there,
except instead of winning championships,
he'd be like bitch moaning
and complaining. And at
one point he made a point,
you know,
they threw it to their big goof there
and that guy fucking missed the ball.
And uh, the guy goes, you know,
if he had a pair of hands,
he would've had two there in front as
he turned around goes, you know what,
you're right.
And the guy just looked at him with
like an angry look like he was,
he was so pissed that Yukon was
losing. And we actually, uh,
you know, I know they're only
having a mediocre year this year.
I mean he can't fucking
win it every year. But um,
you could sense when you
were in there the level,
how seriously everybody was taking it.
Cause [inaudible] he kept saying like,
wow, these people take this
shit really seriously here.
And I just kept pointing up to
all the banners. I'm like, uh,
I would say at this point
they kind of used to winning.
So I guess they're having a
disappointing year, I guess.
I have no idea. I didn't look it
up. I just started talking about it.
It's what I did. But that's why
the podcast, um, was not ready. Um,
I had a great time up
at a Fox Foxwoods, um,
resort casinos, by the way. I
want to thank them for having me.
It was their 24th anniversary,
right. So they say to me, um,
before I get there, they said,
is there any way before your first
show if you could come down, um,
there's a big dinner or something
we'd love if you could meet the, uh,
the tribal council and just
stop by and say, hello. Right.
These are my employers for the weekend.
What am I going to say? No. So I'm like,
absolutely.
I want to meet these native Americans
that fucking beat the white man, you know,
and got their own fucking casino. Right?
So I go down there and I just thought
I was going to swing by a table and say
hello to somebody, thank them for
the Gig. And next thing you know,
they got this whole,
this is like fucking eyes wide shut
fucking dinner going on. You know,
the shining kind of shit in
the bowels of the casino.
There's some band and there's a stage
and it's like this Guy Smiley looking
fucking political guy on stage
and next thing you know he's,
he's given me an intro. I had
no fucking idea I was going on.
I have no idea what these
people are at. Furthermore,
these people had no idea who I was and
I just walk out and I go up. We have,
we got a local 40 man. Yeah, this weekend
please welcome comedian Bill Bern.
I was standing there going,
is he bringing me up?
Is he bringing me up and I
just fucking walk on stage.
I'd take the mic and I was like,
I'm looking out at all these old people
and shit and they just stare at me.
I was like, uh, the cardio
had no idea. I was a,
I was going to be brought
up here, but um, you know,
congratulations on 24 years.
I'm sure most of you people here know
who the next four presidents are going to
be on behalf of regular people.
If you could do something
about the population problem.
I really appreciate it and all of
this shit is getting nothing. Right.
I just started talking to them like they
will run in the world and they're just
looking at me like I got fucking
10 heads and I just said,
I just sort petered out and I
went and uh, onward and upward.
I just handed it back to Guy Smiley and
that was just like a little smattering
of plause and I just walked back into
the hall with the promoters will walk
away. I was like, what the f? What the
fuck was it? And he's like, I don't know.
That's how we talked. Sorry, I didn't,
no one was around doctoral. True ORC.
I won't [inaudible] you know,
nobody knows anything. Right.
And they just fucking wheel you around.
Um, yeah. And then we just fucking,
I think we got on a golf cart
at that point. We, no, no.
We walked through the halls and then they
walked me by the crowd that was going
into my show. So I looked like
a complete jerk off. I fucking,
I love seeing people after the show. I
fucking hate seen people before the show.
I don't know why. I don't if it's a
superstition, it's just weird to me to be,
for me to just be walking by
like the first time you see me,
I'm just walking down the fucking
hall. Oh, there's that jerk off.
And then you just start looking at
why did I pay to see that look at him.
Okay. But anyways, we had a, um,
we had a great fucking time. I had a
bunch of family and friends coming out,
people I hadn't seen in years. Do
you don't mind. My first best friend
and then I ever had in life
actually came up to the Gig. And um,
I hadn't seen him in 36 years. And um,
I was actually thinking the last time
I saw him, you know, the reason why I,
my family, we moved away from the
town that we had lived in. And um,
I just remember we were
both, how fucking old was I?
I think we were like seven or eight.
And you don't know how to say goodbye.
You know, I'd probably been friends
with the kids since I was like four.
So basically half my life I
was friends with this kid.
So we loaded up the moving van the last
time like we would do in the u hall
thing, you know, we'll do it ourselves.
And we just made like 900 fucking trips
in this thing and we were loading it up
for the last time. And uh, he
lived across the street from me.
So I walked down my driveway and he
was out there and he knew this was,
he knew it was it, I knew it was it and
we were just too young. Didn't know.
Yeah, you know what to say. It's seven.
So some kid rode by and had
just written buying a bike.
And I remember he just said
something to me like, Oh yeah,
that kid was trying to say
that, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I couldn't remember anything. I was like,
Oh yeah, you okay? I was like, Oh, I,
uh, and he just started to walk away and
I walked away in the other direction.
And then we both looked over
our shoulder at the same time.
And then that was it. I got in the
fucking u hall and that was it.
He came back to the neighborhood
like four years later.
I saw him one of the
Times. So yeah, 1980. Yes.
Cause I left in 76 some in 80 and then
I hadn't seen him since then. So, uh,
we got caught up talking about
the old fucking times. Man.
We didn't even get into it
either. Man. Jesus Christ,
some of the shit we used to do, you know,
we used to play with fucking matches.
That's what you used to do
back then when there was like,
like playing with matches
was like, I don't know,
like having a game boy or whatever
these fucking kids do nowadays.
And His dad had these things we would,
they would call them monkey matches.
That was just a book of matches.
And for some reason they,
it just had a picture of a monkey
like wearing like a hat. Like,
like that was like
highbrow humor back then,
like dress and monkeys up
like human beings, you know.
And also having pictures of
dogs playing poker and Shit,
passing cards underneath the table
with their paws and shit, you know.
So his dad for whatever reason,
always had these matchbooks that had
pictures of monkeys that would like,
you know, dress like dentists, you know,
like lab coats on and shit or just
some stupid fucking hat, you know.
And uh, so we would,
this is what we would do.
We would go over and we would
like basically underneath
the tree we would bunch
up a bunch of pine needles and you would
just light it on fire and just look at
the fire and then try and
put it out. And um, you know,
sometimes you put it out,
sometimes you didn't.
Sometimes a neighbor would
come run it over cars.
Let the fucking you kids though. Yo
Dahlia don't. Um, I did that one time.
I lit it and all of a sudden it
just got completely out of control.
And this guy came running
over the giant trashcan.
They had filled up with water.
Thank fucking Christ and um,
and then somebody else in
the neighborhood, I remember
fucking lit it on fire.
Let the whole fucking woods
on fire. And uh, I know,
I know it was two because he rode
down to the fire station and,
and said that he didn't do it,
but he knows that he knew that my friend
did it and he fucking ratted out my
friend.
And I'm sure the fire department was
looking at the kid looking at him like,
listen, you little rat, we know
you fucking did it. Right. Um,
so whatever was cool to see him. And um,
I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about. I,
I hate doing this thing after I've
been on a fucking plane, you know. Oh,
you know, I watched on the
plane for the second time,
I saw the movie a black mask, you know,
I know that that Kinda got mixed
reviews. That's one of those movies.
You got to see it more than
once. See it the second time.
The Johnny Depp is fucking
unbelievable in that movie.
He's unfucking believable. And, um,
there's a couple of actors here.
I got to get their fucking names.
They were absolutely amazing, but, uh,
I liked it the first time. I loved
it the second time I saw it. So, um,
you know, I know I, but most people
I heard from were from Massachusetts.
They're like, dude, fucking xs. You
just shut the fuck up. You know,
when I went to Fargo, they were bitching
about the fucking accents in Fargo.
Does that mean Fargo is a bad movie?
I want to, why don't we hire you,
who's not an actor?
We'll have you fucking do it and
we'll see how that works out. But, um,
I just felt, you know, the second time
when I saw it, like the pacing of it,
I felt like they tied it in to like the
absolute sociopath main character that
they will try, you're fucked up is
I'm nervous about talking about this,
the level of power that those
fucking guys had. Um, his,
he reminded me of the Shawshank
redemption where a lot of people,
I know the first time they saw that
they didn't like that movie because they
felt it was so long and was dragging
on and on and on and on. But, um,
my,
my theory on that movie was they were
giving you the sense of what it was like
to do time where it becomes
like this open ended thing.
No beginning, no middle, no end.
It actually sounds like I'm
shitting on the movie, but it just,
the way it would fade down and then
just fade up and every time in the crowd
you'd like be anticipating that there'd
be this major turn and it was just
another day in prison.
A few years later. Um,
I kind of felt like they were trying to
do that with the weighty bulgy character
where, um, you know, they were saying
like, he was a sociopath, like they,
and how he slowly drew in the FBI guys
to the point that they were entangled in
his bullshit. Um, and he
insulated himself that way.
I really, I dunno, maybe I was too dumb
to get all of that shit the first time,
but the second time I
watched it, like I said,
I went from liking that movie to fucking
loving that movie. So, um, whatever.
Give it a shot if you haven't,
but I'm speaking of which
the fucking Oscars well,
last night, huh? White
guys fucking crushing it.
Oh, we fucking sweet.
Cleaned up last night.
I'm just fucking with you man.
That was a, a, I only got to see,
I got to see Chris Rock's opening
monologue, which I thought was great.
I thought he handled the
whole thing fucking perfectly.
Um,
and uh, what else did I see?
I didn't see a lot cause right as
it started, the show was starting.
I think we had a nine o'clock show. We
started a little bit after eight, but,
um, I have no idea who won what.
I know the Boston movie about the
fucking pedophile priest. I heard that,
that thing one,
um,
that was it. Nobody fell
down. Nothing else happened,
right.
Oh, very quietly. The
first, uh, Asian director,
I believe ever fucking won something. Is
that what I saw? I don't know. This is,
you know, just a recurrent thing.
I'm not going to look anything up.
I'm just going to start talking about
it and uh, you know, that's gonna be it.
Okay.
You know what, I don't understand.
Like I don't understand the weight
that people put on the fucking Oscar.
So I really got to tell you that
though. You know what I mean?
Okay.
I just don't, I don't fucking get
it. I was joking this weekend,
like just sitting there watching a bunch
of adults running around wanting to win
a trophy. It's like, well, what
are you fucking little league
trophies are for kids, aren't they?
You have ribbons and shit and it makes
them feel good and you'd take them out
for a fucking snow cone and then that's
it. You know, you put them to bed,
you get yourself a whiskey and you sit
there and you stare at the wall and
that's basically your life. I mean,
why would he, how old are you?
You need a fucking
trophy. Um, yeah. I don't,
I don't give a shit about like
that type of stuff, but I,
I definitely think that there should
be opportunity for everybody. You know,
I'd like to hear everybody's stories. Um,
so I had no problem with
any of that shit. Um,
but I do just think it's funny that
people fucking flip out and start crying
about winning a goddamn trophy. And
this trophy means more than natural fee.
This one's more prestigious.
Um, alright, let's,
I gotta do a couple reads here for this
week. The fuck am I clicking on there?
All right. Um, Jesus Christ,
Trunk Club, everybody, uh,
no matter what time of year it is, you
have got to make every second count.
No you don't. You can chill out.
You know, you can sit down on a,
on a deck or maybe your neighbor's deck
if he's not home and just fucking put
your feet up and enjoy yourself
no matter what time of year it is.
You've got to make every second count.
It sounds like a workout video
and that means looking your best.
No more ratty jeans or oversized
hoodies. Recent college graduates.
It's signed to upgrade your wardrobe and
let trunk club handle all the work for
you.
Trunk Club takes the hassle man out of
shopping by finding the best clothes for
you and your style.
You'll look and feel amazing and we'll
always have the perfect clothes for your
season. Oh my God. Tonic
here. Believe, Oh God,
you look sorry. Uh,
at Trunk club.com/berg you answer simple
questions about your style preferences,
STI size, and are assigned an
expert stylist. What do you mean x?
They're working for trunk club.
If they were an expert when they have
the old fucking line of clothing,
your stylists will handpick clothes
from the best premium brands.
Just approve of what you like and send
back what you don't like and just like
that. A trunk full of fucking cloves
alive. Arise right on your doorstep.
Filled with handpicked clothes
that are perfect for you.
Try them on. Keep what you like. Yeah,
try him on. Don't just stare them out.
You know, don't just look at him stupid.
Keep what you like and easily return
what you don't in their prepaid trunk.
Trunk Club is not a subscription service.
You only pay for the clothes you keep
from your trunk. No hidden charges,
just great clothes. Get started today at
Trunk Club and Trunk Club,
sorry, will style you for free.
Plus free shipping both ways.
You only pay for the clothes that
you keep take to take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/burr that's trunk
club.com/bar ha trunk
club.com/burb all right.
Dollar Shave Club. Everybody. You guys,
evidently according to this
copy, I've figured it out.
Evidentaly I've discovered the key to an
amazing shave isn't so weird that they
would write that like, like I
would actually say that, hey guys,
I've figured it out and you'd be like,
one, I'm not to work and make more money.
No better than that. I've started. I
discovered the key to an amazing shave.
Okay,
sorry. All right. You know what?
Why would you have that big of a fucking
intro for something as stupid as just
shaving your face? Okay. The
reality here is you have, you get,
you get a good shave for a little amount
of money that that's all that's going
on here. Okay? We're not curing cancer.
Let's get back to the copy. It's simple.
That's exactly what dollar shave club
does.com does and why you could be a proud
member like millions of others.
Dollar Shave club.com delivers amazing
razors right to your door for third of
the price of what those
greedy razor corporation cons.
Charge both your wallet and your
face. Finally, get some relief.
Joni Dollar Shave club.com means you
can afford to shave with a fresh blade
anytime you want,
which feels fantastic and
for the smoothest shave ever.
Use their fresh.
Use Your fresh dollar shave club blade
with their doctor cabbies. Easy shape
[inaudible]
it's not your average shave cream.
It's high quality ingredients
to make your skin feel soft,
smooth and moisturized.
Your blade will glide gently across your
skin if you want the most amazing shave
possible. Take it from me.
Use a fresh dollar shave club blade
and Dr cabbies. Easy shave butter.
Two reasons to join dollar shave
club.com/bar today. That's dollar shave
club.com/bar and lastly, but
certainly not Lezley our old friends,
stamps.com hey everyone,
your to do lists can seem out of control
so much to do but so little time.
But there's one thing you could check
off your to do list that's going to the
Goddamn motherfucking
cock sucking post office.
Thanks to stamps.com with stamps.com you
can buy and print official US postage
right from your own computer or printer
stamps.com we'll send you a digital
scale, right?
You can weigh your drugs on it and
mail something to your grandmother
automatically.
It calculates the exact postage
you need for any letter or package,
any class of mail, print the postage you
need, put it on your letter or package,
and then just hand it to your mail
carrier and you're done. Alright,
I use stamps.com anytime I'm
selling bullshit after my
show and I'm a moron if I
can figure it out. Oh God
dammit. So can you, and if not,
you can find someone that can help
you out right now. Use My last name,
birth for this special offer, four
week trial plus a $210 bonus offer,
which includes the digital scale
and up to $55 free postage.
For Christ's sake, don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarburthatstamps.com
enter
bar.
All right. And with that, it's
mercifully over smart. Softly over.
Um, all right. I don't
know if you guys know this,
but I guess they're working on cars that
are going to drive themselves in the
future. Um, I don't know why.
I mean, how fucking lazy are
people going to get? I mean,
it's going to be great for drinking and
driving. It just be drinking and riding.
You know, you, all of a sudden you'll
always have that fucking thing, right?
I don't, I don't like this man.
I don't like how everything's
becoming fucking automated. You know?
I feel like rich people have
gradually phasing us out,
you know,
cause you know God damn well the only
reason why they allow us to exist is
because they need us to farm, right?
They need us to deliver shit. They
need us to do a bunch of shit.
And I guy could add another
example. I don't know,
dance around like a monkey
at a fucking casino.
Come downstairs to say a couple of words
that your little fucking Illuminati
party in the basement.
They need us to do that.
But once everything is automated and
it just handles it, it's fucking self.
Okay.
Do you think you could
be a part of that group?
What if you were part of a group that
was just going to slowly fucking just
phase everybody else out? You know,
and some hours would
happen in your lifetime.
All right
Mike, who would you keep these
free Hitler s type questions.
But this is the type of fucking madness
that I think everybody's capable of.
You know, especially, um, I don't
know if you travel on the road,
some of the dope should fucking meet out
there. Watch people getting stirred up.
You know, in all honesty,
I can't stand like the choices that we
have for president right now, you know,
is it starts to go towards
as a fucking torpedo, uh,
that fucking St Bernard Looking Guy,
Bernie Sanders, right? His javas.
Um, as a torpedo, his fucking campaign
and all democrats are walking around,
he can't win. He can't win.
I love that. I love it. Yeah.
Cause you're too much of a pussy to
fucking vote from. That's why, right?
So you're going to vote for this fucking,
this clammy fucking crook or this guy
who isn't saying anything, but like,
I really believe that, you know,
you could talk people into fucking
wiping out everybody on the planet.
He very easily just
listening to Donald Trump,
his speeches where he just says
absolutely nothing. Do you know,
he said today he was talking to college
graduates and he's literally go with
[inaudible]. I'm going to bring jobs
back to the United States. You wait,
there's going to be more jobs
here by the time I'm done.
It's going to make your head
spin. I'm going to have,
I'm going to have apple
bring manufacturing jobs
back from China to here.
Okay. And people clapped.
He never has to say how
he's going to do all,
I'm gonna plug up the hole in the
ozone layer. Water's going to be clear.
I'm going to get rid of all terrorism
and that's going to be the first week.
Woo.
I like this guy. This guy makes
sense. He's making it great again.
You know, and then you
got Hillary. I'll just,
just talks through her fucking
teeth. It's like she, you know,
she looks like she should be
doing like a ventriloquist act,
but the puppet isn't. Um,
that's cute. Fucking, I dunno.
I have no, I don't know. I
don't fucking know. No idea.
And I don't even know
who the other guys are.
I just heard a couple of them talking,
trying to trash Donald Trump and
they just, they sounded pathetic.
Just not good speakers. This is just a,
this is a bad one is a bad one. Yeah.
I've got bet people
watching, you know, you know,
if you've got a great college program
and a bunch of seniors fucking graduate
graduate and you just, you know, you
just go through a bad four year period.
I think that's what we're coming
through. We're coming out of right now.
You know, like this one guy who was seen,
he was going to get rid of
Obamacare if he was elected.
And people like applauding, like
I, I just, I don't fucking get it.
I don't get why I don't
even, I don't have Obamacare.
I guess my tax dollars paid for it, but
I don't have any problem with somebody.
Like, I don't want it.
My fellow countrymen walking around
with a fucking toothache, you know,
they just spleen removed. Fuck
you. Figure it out for yourself.
Why don't we help each other out a little
more? You know, why can we do that?
And if felt like anybody
needs this, split them out.
Donald Trump, I bet I could run.
I could run for president if that's all
you gotta do is just say you're going to
do all this awesome shit.
You never fucking do it.
Everyone will have healthcare and
it will be free. All right. Um,
okay.
Oh, this weekend, by the way,
all the self driving cars,
let's get back to that fucking thing.
So evidently some self
driving car hit a bus,
which is fucking tremendous
for anybody who loves driving.
That is such a tremendous fucking thing
that happened today or yesterday or
maybe last year. All I know is
I just found the fucking story.
I'm so fucking psyched.
So the self driving car hit the
fucking hit the fucking bus.
I mean it even though it was only
going like two miles an hour,
it's just so fucking great
because it hit a bus.
So all you gotta say is just, you
know, just be like, well what if,
what if there was a bunch
of kids on that bus? Right.
And then that'll delay it a
good 20 fucking years. Um,
let me see if I can find
this story. Self driving.
Google says it bears some responsibility
after self driving car hits bus.
Okay.
Can you fucking believe
that? What was there,
was there a person driving the
bus? I would say that you, you,
you have all the fucking responsibility.
Unless this guy literally
drove into the fucking thing.
Alphabet incorporate, incorporate
a Google set on Monday.
It bears some responsibility after one
of its self driving cars struck a menu,
municipal bus in a minor
crash earlier this month,
the crash may be the first case of one
of its autumn autonomous cars hitting
another vehicle and the fault
of the self driving car.
Dude, this is going to be a shit show.
This is just one and had
already hit a fucking bus.
You know what I mean? That's fucking,
that's lunacy. It's fucking lunacy man.
I will tell you it. I
mean I think it'll, it'll,
it will cause people to drink like
they've never drank before. I mean
have most nights. I don't drink
out of here because I, you know,
I drive myself places, you
know, I don't fucking Uber.
Well that'll put Uber
out of business. Right?
Well I guess if you don't
have a fucking car, I dunno.
Don't you guys like driving?
I'll be at like the option,
my thing is how is the
Insurance gonna work?
Cause you know God damn well there's
no way the insurance company's going to
take that fucking liability on and that
they're claiming they're going to get
rid of. There'll be no more
deaths from car accidents.
It's going to be no more
accidents. It's just going to be,
it's going to be like just accident free.
This is amazing to me that this debt,
it's gotten this fucking far considering,
you know that like the amount of times
they tried to kill the electric car,
right? And you know, big oil
companies, that type of thing.
You mean you fucking with it. They have
blue blood money going out. Having that,
let's go electrocute an elephant to show
how fucking dangerous these cars are.
Right? So
like this is the only thing I can think
of what these insurance companies,
they're making enough money to go down
there and whack somebody at ABC Inc.
Right? You know, they
fucking do shit like that.
And you go to a diner and all of
a sudden you stagger outgoing.
They poisoned me and he'd do a face
plant. Then your invention disappears.
Oh I'm going down the rabbit hole.
This is why I think they are letting
this one go through cause they're
eventually going to get rid of all of us
and when they do that they're going to
have no more limo drivers. So
they're like, whoa, whoa, whoa.
What are we going to do in the
future if we want a Rudge somewhere?
I mean I'm not going to drive my
car and soil my wealthy hands Elmo.
And then somebody is like,
well what if we just had,
we'll just make the cars drive themselves.
Oh, okay then. Okay. Kill
them all then. Yes, thank you.
Poison them, remove them
from the point on it.
Um, I wonder if they got rid of everybody,
how long it would take for this
phone, you know, to go back to,
normally you have to take all the
nuclear waste, right? Just send it out,
you know, out in the fucking
space. Right. Send it towards Mars.
Just make sure you don't hit the moon
and all you do is just fucking chill out.
Nearly a little house. And when I
along it would take to undo all Abbott.
All is shit that people
leave behind. You know,
fucking going to deal with all of that.
That's all going to go into
the soil and take a, he ain't,
I wouldn't happen in your
lifetime. Jesus Christ.
I am all over the place, man. What
the fuck am I talking about here?
The murdering people, self driving
cars used to see this fucking car.
By the way, this fucking self driving car,
it makes the Volkswagen beetle
look like a Goddamn Lamborghini.
People on the Simpsons drive a better
looking car than that fucking thing.
Oh, you know, they're all gonna be
the exact same fucking one, right?
You'll have your options of like
three different colors, like white,
black or beige.
Oh Man, this is not uplifting. I'll
tell you what's uplifting. March 5th,
this weekend, UFC one
96. Conor McGregor, um,
UFC one 96. What are they
calling this one? Did they,
did they stop naming
them though, by the way?
To have they come up with
196 adjectives that, that,
that describe how fucking tremendous
that sports, that sport is.
You know, you have c 12, the
redemption, the revenge or whatever.
They always had like these cool fucking
names up to once you get up to like one
96, they gotta be running out. Right.
Let me see what they got here.
UFC one 96 Conor McGregor versus some
Guy Dia's I wish I knew these guys names
better. You know, there's only so
much shit I can pay attention to.
Um, these taking on late replacement,
Nate DHEAS. Ah, Jesus. What happened?
He was supposed to fight somebody else.
Rafio I'm not going to fucking insulted
Latinas by trying to pronounce it,
although I could give
you a good laugh here.
Rafi el Dos anules Raphael sign yells.
I'm was from his showdown against
Connor with a broken foot out.
F it the fuck. Do you know I was
reading something on McGregor today?
Do you know? I don't understand. I
don't. Somebody in the fight game,
please explain this to me. That guy
walks around at one 70 and he shredded
and then before his fight
for whatever fucking reason,
he's got to go down to one 45.
Now I can understand if the other guy
just walks around at one 45 or maybe one
55 and Connor for whatever reason,
just wants to beat the
fuck out of the guy.
So he's willing to starve himself
down to one 45 for the love of God.
Can anybody in the fight game that
let that does this, why can't,
you know,
if Carter walks around at one 70 and the
other guy's walking around at one 65,
why don't they just fight it like one 60?
Why do they got to bring everybody
all the way the fuck down there? I, I,
I just don't understand why
they got to do that shit. Um,
check out the sports illustrated
article on, uh, on Conor McGregor.
They got like this whole thing where
the only briefly talk about it, uh,
but they're talking about cutting weight
and it actually sounds in a lot of
ways, worse than the fight, like talking
about the pain and the agony of it.
And it's, I, I can't even, uh,
I'm not going to be able to do it
justice because I just read it.
I have a very poor memory and I've
never gone through it. But, uh,
Holly Holmes also fighting
against, uh, Meesha tape and, uh,
I'm taking the night off of stand
up and I'm going to fucking hang it.
You know what's great?
This is the one sport that I
can really watch my wife like,
she likes going to live hoop too,
but she loves the fucking UFC.
She gets into it like at a crazy level.
Like that time when that guy kicked, uh,
kicked the other dude and he had
the compound fracture, you know,
and his fucking leg bent all
the way back. I was just like,
I walked out and my guy done
done. I can't watch that. She,
she was rewinding it, wanting
to watch it again and was like,
like literally interested in it. Um,
which means she either should have
been a serial killer or gotten into the
medical field because if you
can fucking stomach that, um,
either way I can, I'm, I'm really
excited to see this shit this weekend.
I like it. Even if they're quick
fights, even though if it's a bad thing,
does it make you at least want to workout?
You see those guys and fucking
women getting in there,
they're all fucking jacked.
You look down at yourself,
usually finishing off
a pizza. You're like,
what the fuck am I doing going
down to Home Depot tomorrow?
I'll get a sledgehammer and
a big fucking tire, you know,
and you know what you're doing for
a couple of days and then you quit.
And that's why you're not a champion.
Like what you're going to see on
fucking Saturday. There you go.
There's my promo for
the UFC. Um, all right,
let's, uh, let's, let's read some
fucking letters for this week. Shall We?
Everybody, chances are because
Cleo, you're losing
your figure sweetheart.
Glad you didn't walk the red carpet
at the, uh, at the fucking Oscars.
They would've been all over you. All
right. Leaving the country of Trump wins.
Dear Billy elect,
what's your take on people who say
they're going to leave the comp country if
Trump wins, uh,
besides the potential for lanes
to open up on the highway?
I just hope the people that say
they're going to leave leave,
so I don't have to point out
who's allying sec is shit. Um,
they're obviously joking. No one's
going to leave this country, but, uh,
it's just, you know, he's a
very extreme guy. You know.
I think people said that when Obama,
they definitely said it during George
Bush with some famous stars set it.
I remember, I thought it was like funny.
Then of course Fox News
is launch your league.
Why don't you get the fuck Outta here?
You know, like fucking lunacy. Um,
what do I think about people say that? I
think it's kind of Hacky at this point.
I think that's what everybody says.
When there's somebody that's on the
fringe on one side of the other,
somebody always ends up going
and you have to go, fucking went,
I'm going to leave. Where are you going
to go? This is what people forget.
When you, uh, when you
leave this country, you,
you immediately become an immigrant
who's taking somebody else's job in the
country that you're going to and
you get treated as such. You know,
even if you white, they don't want,
but they don't want Americans moving up
to Canada fucking with their population,
taking their jobs. You know,
all of a sudden you're standing this
drive and a spike into a tree to take out
some maple syrup instead of the
other guy. They don't want that.
They don't want that
at all. Um, all right.
Yeah, I just think they're just the
saying. I mean it's, it's fucking scary.
I mean, it's supposed scary.
I think Hillary is a fucking lion
sack. A Shit, a totally dishonest.
And I think a Donald Trump
is a reality show star.
That's the best we can fucking
do. I just don't fucking get it.
It keeps getting worse.
Okay.
Jay's is fucking the last guy.
The last guy that I thought was decent
was the first George Bush. You know,
I like when he went into Kuwait and
then like he teach it. All right.
That's enough. That's enough.
He didn't go off fucking nuts
and we got the fuck out of there.
Okay.
You know, and then fucking
Clinton came in. I,
what the fuck down was a big frat party
where he's getting his dick sucked.
He's lying about shit. People got stuff
on them, mysteriously die. I mean,
it was fucking nuts.
Then he bombed some people to get
out of a fucking blow job accusation.
The whole fucking thing was, I don't
know. It's been crazy ever since. Um,
I don't know shit about politics. Don't
listen to me. All right. Boyfriends,
smoking habit. Hey Mr Burr, love
the podcast and the stand up.
Come to Rochester, New York soon. Uh, I
would love all, you know what, you know,
what is a buffalo date and a
Syracuse state in the works.
Yes ma'am. Yes sir. Whatever. Wherever
this is writing this shit. Um,
uh, with the F I just scroll down,
sorry. Love the podcast and the stand up.
Come to Rochester, New York.
I would appreciate some advice from
yourself and the lovely Nia if she's
available. Uh, she ain't
here today, man. All right.
I've been with my boyfriend for
almost two years and since day one,
I knew of his daily weed smoking habit.
He doesn't let her let it hinder
his life. Still very social,
faithful, going to, going to
work every day. Uh, he scheduled,
he eats healthy and he goes to
the gym four to five days a week.
I've tried getting used to it, um,
since it's something that he does and
it, it isn't a problem in his life,
but I've never wanted
to try drugs or alcohol.
So I don't know what the feeling of
being under the influence of something is
like now because now, because of that,
my problem is unless I see him during
the day and even then he'll take a hit,
he's not sober.
Is it wrong of me to be concerned
that whenever he sees me,
he's under the influence of something? Uh,
whenever we go to the
movies or a comedy show,
he'll bring half a cookie so we
can quote, enjoy the show more.
And why don't I want him to relax after
work by vaping a and hanging out with
me. Considering this habit hasn't,
hasn't hindered his life in any way.
Do I have a reason to be uneasy about
this? I understand why he does it.
And he tells me it doesn't affect his
feeling about feelings about me and about
us being together, but it still makes
me uneasy whenever I know he's high.
Um,
yeah. Well, I mean if you don't like it,
you don't like it. And if he enjoys it,
he enjoys it. So you both
know where you stand.
Um,
I gotta be honest. I mean, if
someone was drinking every day,
there would be probably
an issue with that.
Although there's no medicinal
purposes for a alcohol is there,
unless they're taking an
arrow out of your back,
don't think like rubbed some
on your gums or some shit.
I can't remember how it goes. You
take a shot. Is that what it is?
You bite down on a fucking
garden hose? I don't remember.
Um,
yeah. I mean if these getting fucking
begged all the time and he always,
you know, so he'll enjoy it more. Yeah,
that's a little bit of a red flag,
you know, honestly,
if you fucking doing it every day and
you're never really sober and you just
sort of constantly just sorta hi, um,
that's probably not a good way to go
through life, but it is his choice.
I would just tell him, just be like,
look, I'm not saying you can't smoke,
but like if you're high
all the time and I'm sober,
so I'm constantly talking
to a buzzed you and,
um, it bothers me.
Okay.
I would just tell him that and I,
I think that it's gonna bother him
because when you fucking smoke weed like
that, it's a religion, you know what
I mean? It's not like, you know,
every day he comes home and
he does this one little thing,
puts his shoes in the
wrong spot or some shit.
This is like you're talking about his
state of consciousness when he's around
you at all fucking times. Basically.
You want him to alter that.
So that's some kind of a major change.
Um,
you didn't tell me how old he
was, but, um, I don't know.
I don't know much about weed. I know
some people say they get productive when,
when they're, when they're using it and
that type of stuff. But, uh, I dunno, I,
I really feel that, you know,
and this is somebody who's like,
realized that his drinking
is out of control again.
So I just thought I've stopped
for the last fucking three days.
Um,
I mean, I really have to
watch it with myself. Okay.
Because I have the kind
of job where, you know,
I can get fucked up every night
basically, and then sleeping the next day.
Now granted my career would suffer and
I wouldn't get anywhere and eventually,
you know, but I mean, I
could do some stuff before,
like I might career totally did a
fucking nosedive provided I didn't like,
you know, do something stupid
like fucking, you know,
get behind the wheel of a
car, fucking assault somebody.
If I was just getting
drunk every day. Um, yeah,
that would affect where
I was in the business.
But it'd be like a long seven
year, like tapering off, you know,
back to doing the comedy vault
at Remington's in Boston,
which doesn't exist anymore. But, um,
you know, I, I don't
know, I just personally,
I know I really got to watch it in my, my,
my finger about people who smoke weed
is the fact that they could be on it and
nobody really knows. Like, you know,
when once they're high all
the time they're experienced
being high and they can
just go to work being high and,
uh, you can't do that drunk.
He can't go to work like, you
know, shotgun a beer and walk in.
People just know it just doesn't work. Um,
but I'm not exactly a hundred percent
exact against it the way I used to in the
early days of this podcast when
I didn't know a lot about it.
Now I'm understanding that
there's certain people,
you don't have to have really active
minds. They need to fucking chill out.
It's actually a great
thing, um, for them. But I,
I really think if you're doing it all
the fucking time like that, yeah. Like,
this is probably cause for an issue
there, you know, to bring it up like, hey,
you kind of fucking basically wasted
every time I talked to you. And then also,
you know, that whole thing, you know,
he brings half a cookie
so he can enjoy the show.
It's like you can't enjoy it
sober. Like those are kind of some,
um, red flags.
Hmm.
I Dunno. And I also think that you can
get addicted to that shit. You know,
I think, I think it guy is, to be
honest with you, people always say Nah,
you're not really addicted to it. Oh
yeah. You just do it every waking moment.
You can't fucking enjoy something
unless you're under the influence of it.
There's something there.
It's just because it's such a
mellow thing and it's not like a,
you know, I guy a bug and a buddy
of mine from back in the day, dude,
he's completely fucking
addicted to that shit. He says,
I love weed cause it turns
my life into a movie. And um,
no, basically been high since we
were sophomores in high school. And,
uh, without a doubt it's fucked with
his memory. Without a doubt. Its,
it's fucked with his drive, you know,
I dunno, I understand.
Wanting to get fucked up every
day. Personally. It's fun.
It's think with weed, it's so easy,
a couple of puffs and then boom,
you're there, you know,
drink. It takes it off. Gee,
I've got to stop talking about
this. I'm going to have a drink.
I'd set up to take a week off here, so.
All right, well good luck with that.
I would just, I would just say how you're
feeling and um, if it gives, you know,
gives you shit back, I'd just
be like, look, give me, I'm,
I'm not being an asshole here.
You just like, you high every day.
Can you just like not be
high a couple of days a week?
Like how do you do that and not feel
like you're infringing on this guy's
fucking lifestyle? I mean, it's, I
dunno, I would bring it up to him.
As I said 20 minutes ago before
I meandered my way through that.
Sorry about that. All right,
I fucked up. Please advise.
Dear Billy ginger cakes. I
have a 26 year old fucking
lady who is a tremendous fan of your
work in all its glorious forms. Well,
thank you very much.
A that seen enough as for family with the
dad balls when bill is stuck under the
bed is the funniest fucking thing I've
ever seen. Brilliant. Well thank you.
I appreciate that. Um, I did.
I did something really then.
All capital's really dumb and I would
greatly appreciate your insight because I
know you will tell me the ever elusive
truth. I won't tell you why I won't.
I'll tell you what I think is the
truth, whether it's the right answer.
You got it. You got to
decide that for yourself.
I had been friends with this guy for
about two years and now you're fucked them
in. You ruin the friendship. That's
what I'm, that's what I'm guessing here.
We met through a larger group of friends.
There was chemistry between
us immediately. This guy,
his Sophie's married,
try and see where, how, how the, how
this can go off the rails. This are,
this is reading in the beginning, like
one of those dating sites, you know,
they play that stupid piano.
Hulu do, but do, do that stupid
woo
dumb shit. Let's see. Area killer.
This could be a sex
offender. I don't know.
No. Whoa. Uh, we met
through a larger, larger
group of friends. There was
chemistry between us immediately.
This guy is so funny and so
smart and fun to be around.
The problem is he has two penises.
I'm kidding. She didn't write that.
But he's also a complete
and total whore. Oh, Jesus.
Crushing it and good for him, but
exactly the wrong guy to get hung up on.
I knew I liked him too
much. I couldn't help it,
but I thought I could handle being
friends, friends with him. And eventually,
eventually the feelings
would pass. Nah, Nah.
You can't be around guys like that. This
guy's a pussy getting son of a bitch.
Right. Dracula would be like, God
damn it. That guy's got game right.
And all the, all the ladies Love Dracula.
He'd come up and start knocking on
their fucking necks and that was it.
Tournament to lady bats. Right.
Then he kicked him to the curb,
get himself another
chick the next day. Um,
we started hanging out a lot, at least
two or three nights a week. Sometimes.
He said things that made me
think maybe he liked me too.
Then on my birthday we got
drunk and had sex called it. Oh,
Jesus. She says, let me
be clear. He started it.
I just didn't stop it even
though I knew it was a bad idea.
So like a little kid, he started it. Um,
the worst part is when I woke up the
next morning in his bed, in his bed,
he was gone. Oh Man.
He fled the fucking same bill.
The dude shaped hole in the door.
One told that he was freaked out.
The dude shaped hole in the door. He mean
even like Lilly ran through the door.
I think he left some words out or
I'm too fucking old to understand,
is that some new slang. Uh,
told me he was too freaked out and decided
and I decided to give him some space.
He called me four days later.
I don't remember the
conversation or were you drunk,
but he said he'd call me back.
That was four months ago.
Clearly he doesn't give
a shit. I get that,
but I cannot understand how we could be
so much in my life and then just never
fucking talk to me again. The fuck dude.
The fuck you sound cool as
hell. By the way. The more,
the more immediate problem is that in
a few weeks a mutual friend is having a
birthday party and dude is going
to be, is going to be there.
What the fuck do I do, Bill? How
do I face him? Do I confront him?
Do I ignore him? I'm bugging out. Please
help me. Thank you with any advice.
Um, the has got a God, I wish
she was here this week. Um,
all right, here's the deal.
Yeah.
All right. This isn't about him.
This is about you. All right.
Be honest with yourself. He kind of
said, you knew what this guy was.
You knew who he was. All right?
But he just had that fucking thing.
All right. He just had that fucking
charisma or whatever. And two years,
two years into it, you'd drunk.
He started it and you went
through with whatever, you know.
He got freaked out and confirmed what you
knew all the time and he fucking left.
All right. That'd be honest with
me. Do you want to fight that fight
before you met this guy and you
fantasized about the man you were going to
marry? Was this how it was
going to play out? Was this,
does this something that you
want to fucking deal with?
You realize you're going to have to like
trying to bring this fucking fish in
the amount of heartache,
the amount of extracurricular activities
and all that fucking shit that comes
along with a guy like this?
Well, why would you do that?
Why would you do that to yourself?
You don't need this shit. All right.
Okay.
The problem is is you're trying to, like,
you're trying to like figure out the
sanity in somebody insane behavior.
Okay?
You knew what he was and then he
confirmed it and now you're like, dude,
does he mean this? He said,
how could he just do that?
Because he's a fucking load
of tech. He's a load of tech.
Who knows because his dad ran around on
his mom because his mom took off on his
dad. Who the fuck knows
cause they his bullshit,
his giant truck load of
fucking bullshit. Okay.
That he is still not
even begun to deal with,
which is why he's behaving
like that around you.
You don't fucking need that Jesus Christ.
All the guys in the fucking world go
to the party and have a good time.
Hm.
Just tell him just, you know, if
you see him, just say what's up.
No need to be weird.
Okay. It's over. Whatever.
Where we had a good time. It's
fucking over. I knew you were nuts.
Now you confirmed it. All right.
Stop fucking looking at me like
you've seen it go like I just,
I would just go there and have a
good time. I wouldn't ignore him.
I wouldn't confront him.
I would just say hello and then
I would go on what's happening?
If he wants to talk, talk
to him. If he doesn't,
just go on with having a good
time. If you bumped into him again,
say hello again, but don't let that
fucking guy ruin your good time.
All right.
And quit fucking wasting mental time
trying to figure out his bullshit.
He's not worth it. Fuck them. All
right. There you go. Fuck them. Hey,
who knows? She might meet
Mr Right at that place.
Ooh. Wow.
Great everlasting love.
A documentary suggestion.
Dear Billy Boo,
if you haven't seen the documentary on
Netflix about the Ukraine revolution,
you should definitely check it
out. I would love to see that. Um,
it's called winter on fire.
That sounds like a really bad 80 song.
Okay.
Where Gerrard Fi
what does that sell? Say it almost fire.
How I can fight some fucking Russians.
I don't like Vladimir Putin. I'm sorry.
And the immortal words of Ron
Burgundy. Wow. That escalated quickly.
My singing or the Ja, the documentary.
It starts with some activists
deciding to congregate in one place,
which started as an event sent out on
Facebook and ended up replacing their
president.
[inaudible]
yeah. Every time I reached you like this,
like I am amazed at the human spirit
and also feel so fucking lucky that I
haven't had to experience
that in a country. You know,
I I the country I live and we haven't
gone through some shit like that.
Hopefully it will never fucking happen
because I don't think I could stomach it.
You know, hearing when people
running up and down the street,
you're just sitting there in the house.
Okay.
Who was in charge?
Um,
the idea is so foreign to us and I think
most people don't understand just how
crazy it is. Yeah. I mean I don't,
I'm trying to wrap my head around it,
but you are really good
at seeing crazy shit.
No one notices that is
right under our noses.
So I think you'll be floored by this.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. What?
Thank you for the a, the recommendation.
I will definitely try to, uh,
check that out as soon as I can. Is that
all the shit? Is that all the fucking
what am I up to here? 58
minutes and 56 seconds.
I think I can bullshit for another
minute and call this a God damn day.
Was there something else that I had
to talk about here on the podcast? Um,
oh yeah. I decided, uh, I ran
into a buddy of mine and he, uh,
told me his new year's
new year's resolution was,
he wasn't going to argue with his wife
this year and he's made it all the way to
February. I was like, you know what,
that's a really cool resolution and
I haven't made any this year. So, um,
I'm not giving up arguing with my
wife, uh, for two reasons. One,
it would destroy my act into I'm
a selfish son of a bitch. Um,
at first I have no control of my fucking
emotions. I don't, it's shameful,
but I don't. Um, so I decided
instead of I'm going to,
I'm trying to get back
into learning French. Uh,
I feel like as I'm approaching, you
know, the mid century mark here,
if I don't fucking do it
now, I'm going to be fucked.
I'm never going to learn how to do it.
Um, so I'm fucking, I'm back into it.
I'm on duo lingo. I've done it
three days in a fucking row.
And the only reason why I'm announcing
it to you guys is because, yeah,
if you don't hear me talking about it,
please break my balls and say that
I fucking quit again. I'm a loser.
And all that type of Sheldon wonderful
positive shit that you guys can see in
knowledge anonymously
on the Internet. Um, oh,
by the way, you know, you know it's
funny in this fucking business,
like they never tell the performer shit.
Right? So I'm on stage this weekend.
I got to ask you if there's
any doctors out there.
I'm fucking onstage and I'm doing my
act. I don't even know what night it was.
It might've been the first show last
night and the whole time I'm doing my act,
everything I fucking say
some guy in the crowd is just like
repeating it or commenting on it,
you know what I mean? Like
not like heckling, it's more
like, like black church,
like call and response. I
was like, yeah, you know,
I was walking down the street the
other day and he says like, yeah,
well I mean down the street, you know,
doing that shit the whole fucking time.
But he's not so loud that the
rest of the crowd can hear it.
Some hoping if I just ignore him,
he's going to stop and he does it.
And finally after like a half
an hour, it's like, dude,
will you shut the fuck up? You don't
have to fucking comment on everything.
He like, all right. All right. All
right. He's just doing that shit,
but I love you.
It takes saying shit like that and you
know I was trashing them and all that
shit.
So afterwards I ended up meeting him
after the show and he ended up telling me
that he had Tourette's and then
somebody on the show go, yeah, yeah,
you had Tourette's. We didn't know if
you should throw them out. It's like,
why don't you fucking tell me that before
I make a fucking ass out of myself?
I felt terrible. But here's my
question, is that a form of Tourette's?
I thought Tourette's is either you're
cursing your brains out or you make weird
noises or you do some
sort of physical tick.
I didn't know that you fucking, all of
a sudden we're doing that, you know,
I'm in a Baptist church, you know,
except doing it in a way that
egs on the fucking speaker.
It actually annoys the shit out of
it. Well, maybe that's my temperament.
I have no idea. Um,
that's my question for somebody
out there in the medical field,
is that a form of Tourette's or was
he just trying to make me feel bad?
I'm literally yawning here like
a fucking idiot. Um, all right.
That's the podcast for
this week. Oh, Biz Billy.
No booze bag is back on the
fucking wagon again. Um,
I gotta tell you as much as I fucking go
up and down with that shit, at least I,
I do nip it in the bud, you know?
I, uh, I just drank too much.
Was it Friday night? Woke up,
fucking hung over, tired as shit.
I was just like, what the fuck am I
doing to myself? This is stupid. And, um,
then I watched black mask and I was
watching them drinking Budweisers in 1970s
pull tab cans. And I was like, God,
I miss that. I miss it already.
All right. All right. That's a
podcast for this week. Sorry. Uh,
it was so late. Um, if you'd like
to contributed to this podcast,
as I tell you that it's late
to, anytime you go to Amazon,
just go through the podcast page, um,
not the podcast page on my
website. Click on the merge page.
You Click on the Amazon link and a,
I get credit for driving people there and
I give 10% of that shit to the St Jude
until you tell me that that
one's a scam to, you know,
everyone that I give to you guys
eventually end up telling me that.
But I think this is a good one.
All right. Go Fuck Yourself.
So talk to you on Thursday.